[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
mein heutiger kraft ist durchaus
unbequem sie spricht aus was andere nur
denken und sie denkt zu ende als andere
verdrängen in ihren kolumnen und bücher
und um die in ihrem philosophischen
fernsehformat street philosophie auf
arte zu sehen geht sie dahin wo es weh
tut manchmal ganz zart dann wieder
knallhart und immer wieder trotzig der
trotz ist für sie denn auch eine art
lebensphilosophie ganz herzlich
willkommen und davonrennen vielen dank
schön sicher sein darf ja frau von rönne
sie haben anfang des jahres ihren
zweiten roman veröffentlicht ende in
sicht darin geht es um zwei ganz
unterschiedliche frauen die auf ihre art
und weise beide eigentlich finden das
leben ist ganz schön eine zumutung
teilen sie diese einstellung prinzipiell
hat man damit recht ich glaube
spätestens nach zwei jahren mit lock
down und corona und krieg auf
europäischem boden mehr denn je die
beiden haben aber auf sehr
unterschiedliche weise mit dem leben wir
haben heller deutlich älter die mit
alters einsamkeit hat was ein thema ist
auch ein politisches außerdem war sie
mal kurzfristig ein gefeierter
schlagerstar und
lebt jetzt lieber gestrig mit dem blick
zurück und findet eigentlich das heute
ist eine zumutung und das morgen noch
viel mehr das sollte man nicht direkt
verbieten dann natürlich auch weil ihr
erfolgen vorbei ist ja so sie hatten
also heller liegt man denkt diese wird
das glück aber es ist eigentlich ein
schlagersternchen dessen stern bereits
untergegangen ist abgehalftert das ist
nicht so viel mehr wie hier genau dann
juli julis 15 und juli leitet würde ich
sagen unter einer depression
aber ich bin tatsächlich nicht
psychologe ich weiß selbst nicht genau
was los ist bei ihr und beide wollen
ihrem leben ein ende setzen und so
begegnen sie sich genau die eine also
die hella die fährt ja in die schweiz
und in die schweiz fahren ist da fast
schon eine metapher in deutschland also
quasi suizidbeihilfe in anspruch nehmen
das andere mädchen also die juli die
stürzt sich von einer brücke und landet
just neben dem der passat von dieser
helle licht und dann beginnt eigentlich
ein rasantes roadmovie dieser beiden
frauen was man vielleicht schon verraten
darf die beiden leben am ende des buches
sind sie haben ja im interview gesagt
sie wollten ein allzu düsteres ende
ihren großeltern nicht zumuten es gibt
das düstere ende das steht auch erst
drin ich glaube es gibt zehn
verschiedene enden die ich geschrieben
habe ich konnte mich nicht richtig
durchdringen auf der einen seite dachte
ich bei ihrem der unter einsamkeit
leidet wie heller und wie viele ältere
menschen das ist ein gesellschaftliches
problem für die gibt es eine lösung am
ende und ich hab was erlebt und für die
ist das roadmovie die verschiedenen
stationen mal wieder leben draußen seine
lösung für jemand mit depression ist es
nicht so einfach da kann man im prinzip
nicht sagen am ende des buches ist
hattest du irgendwie eine wilde woche
und jetzt ist alles gut und am anfang
wollte ich diese depression durchaus
ernst nehmen und das für meine jüngere
nicht ganz so gut ausgehen lassen
dieses mal bei diesem buch mag ich
allerdings meine protagonisten kriegt
gerne und meine großmutter auch also
erlebt tatsächlich auch noch lebt also
die großmutter und
und machte die großmutter in das buch
ist wer sie macht das wirklich gerne
und das ist die wichtigste
großmutter ja oder ja definitiv ganz
ganz toll großmutter die beste sehr
schön nun wenn wir über depressionen
sprechen das thema dieses buch ist es
sich auch sehr klar dass sie über dieses
thema schreiben sie schreiben zum
beispiel auch dass sie ein stück der
einnahmen des hörbuches der deutschen
depressionshilfe spenden werden dass ich
ein anliegen darüber zu sprechen und sie
selber leiden seit ich 17 jahre alt sind
immer mal wieder unter depressiven
schüben situationen gerade kürzlich
mussten sie wieder in die klinik das
wissen wir auch weil sie diese sendung
hier ja absagen mussten ursprünglich am
18 februar haben sie auch gepostet das
ist wieder so weit ist für sie leider
dass sie sich in eine klinik begeben
müssen wir sehen hier den post ein
wunderschönes bild von ihnen sie
beschreiben im text dass sie noch
interviews geben sich fotografieren
lassen und parallel dazu eigentlich mit
der klinik in kontakt sind und auf einen
platz warten also diese parallelität des
glanzvollen ruhmvollen lebens von ronja
von rönne und diesem moment ich muss
ganz ganz düster wird ja ich meine ist
es etwas makaber natürlich zu sagen aber
wenigstens habe ich mir bei diesem buch
viel recherche gespart mein guter freund
benedict wells sagt auf die frage ob das
buch
autobiografisch ist immer alles erfunden
aber alles empfunden das könnte man da
vielleicht irgendwie auch drauf setzen
ich leite irgendwie länger darunter oder
hadere damit es geht nun mal besser mal
schlechter
ursprünglich als ich das erste mal eine
klinik war 2015 war eine lesereise
angedacht viele viele stationen und ich
war so depressiv dass ich mich im bett
nicht von links nach rechts drehen
konnte ich habe nicht mehr auf anrufe
reagiert gar nichts zum glück habe ich
einen sehr sehr tollen freundeskreis die
trotzdem nicht locker gelassen haben und
ich dann über drei bundesländer vernetzt
irgendwo untergebracht haben mich da
hingebracht haben in diese klinik
und dann musste ich jeder der depression
hat oder angehörige hat weiß das ist
eigentlich an sich schon vollzeitjob ist
es ist wahnsinnig anstrengend und
kräftezehrend
dann auch noch ein lügen konzept zu
bauen mit irgendwie ach ich musste
lesereise sagt absagen wegen familiärer
notfall ist furchtbar anstrengend und
deswegen hab ich damals irgendwann
gesagt okay der familiären notfall bin
ich selber ich wollte jetzt gar nicht
unbedingt
eine koryphäe für eine mentale
gesundheits bewegung werden sondern es
war einfach zu anstrengend auch noch
irgendwie diese fassade aufrecht zu
halten es war also eher und
selbsterhaltungstrieb
das feedback war wirklich hinreißend
von professioneller seite auch von
menschen die das damals auf instagram
gesehen haben viele tiere auch
geschrieben haben sie trauen sich jetzt
zum ersten mal selber mit ihrem partner
darüber zu sprechen oder mit ihnen
eltern unterschiedliche alter aber muss
auch dazu sagen in dem beruf einer
autorin ist es deutlich einfacher aber
die depression ist kein künstler beruf
und keine künstler krankheit sondern
eine volkskrankheit und kann absolut
jeden treffen und für mich war es
einfach für viele menschen ist das nicht
nicht für mütter vielleicht die
eingespannt sind oder väter
nicht für menschen weiß nicht im
öffentlichen dienst oder mit familien
die diese krankheit nicht ernst nehmen
wenn ich eine lanze etwas brechen konnte
ist das gut aber ich bin wahnsinnig
privilegiert dass ich diesen offenen
umgang mir leisten kann und wenn sie
sagen es ist eine volkskrankheit und sie
wollen auch ein stück weit ein stick
motivieren auch wenn ich jetzt sagen sie
noch nicht eine botschafterin sein oder
so aber es geht ihnen ja schon auch
darum kann man ja auch mal festhalten
das bundesamt für statistik in der
schweiz sagt dass rund sechs prozent der
schweizer bevölkerung sind gegenwärtig
in behandlung einer psychischen
erkrankung jeder zehnte erkrankt im
laufe seines lebens an einer depression
also sind wirklich hohe zahlen irgendwie
verdrängt man dass man verdrängtes und
erst verdrängt man es vor sich selber
und dann wenn das nicht mehr geht
verdrängt man isst und verstecktes vor
anderen es gibt ja man diesen vergleich
mit eigentlich sollte es genauso sein
wenn man sich ein bein bricht aber ich
glaube es einfach ist es nicht denn auch
für mich und ich bin mittlerweile
wirklich trainierten ist es nicht immer
klar festzustellen ist es gerade
anfangen einer depressiven phase ist es
vielleicht einfach nur
unausgeschlafen haid und tatsächliche
problem ist es nicht so einfach auch das
zu erkennen anzuerkennen sich
einzugestehen und dann sechs prozent
finde ich viel die in behandlung sind
was ein gutes zeichen ist denn
deutschland zumindest ist es wahnsinnig
schwer therapieplätze zu kriegen im
prinzip kann man sagen ist es so
kompliziert dass die leute die die
energie haben das zu schaffen haben
vielleicht gar keine schwere depression
das ist jetzt will ich hart ausgedrückt
weil es so kompliziert ist krieg plätze
ebenfalls ich glaube das ganze ändert
sich jetzt etwas dieser
paradigmenwechsel ist auch dringend
notwendig denn wir haben eine generation
die heranwächst den die jugend geraubt
wurde durch corona die deren
studienjahre nicht mit meinen
vergleichbar sind leute die in isolation
und toxischen beziehungen zu hause
gefangen waren oder einsamkeit aushalten
mussten also mehr denn je wird es
einfach wichtig wir können nicht mehr
nicht drüber sprechen
sie haben vorhin gesagt depression ist
keine künstler krankheit das passiert
aber ganz auf das man fast ein bisschen
mystifiziert und eben hin weist auf die
vielen autorinnen und autoren künstler
künstlerinnen die unter depressionen
oder angststörungen panikattacken
gelitten haben denken sie zum beispiel
an
das bekannte bild der schrei von edvard
munch wo er sozusagen seine
befindlichkeit in öl gebannt hat oder
denken hier an mark twain forst sogar
als großartig autoren die
lebenslänglich gelitten haben unter
dieser kranken oder natürlich auch
schriftstellerin viel applaus der
glasglocke da schreibt sie über eine
figur eine journalistin die depressiv
wird man weiß heute dass vieles davon
auch tatsächlich autobiografisch ist und
diese glasglocke über die sie schreibt
das ist ja wirklich so ein sinnbild
geworden für eine depression ja es ist
ein sehr sehr gutes sinnbild
zudem künstlerin mythos man muss
natürlich sagen in einer depressiven
phase einer schweren depressiven phase
das schafft man nicht sondern im
zweifelsfall weise nicht schneidet man
sich ein ohr ab wie van gogh
ob man später einen mehrwert daraus
ziehen kann funktioniert erst wenn diese
die irgendwie da ein bisschen wieder
einsetzt und nicht mehr wenn dieser
sturm grollt ich glaube aber auch setzt
leute waren sich unter druck denn die
meisten menschen
die depression haben schreiben nicht und
komponieren nicht sondern hadern und
scheitern und
müssen irgendwie noch die kinder von der
schule abholen deswegen finde ich ein
bisschen unfair weil ich bin irgendwie
privilegiert und kann daraus geld machen
möchten wir uns ganz wacker sagt für die
meisten ist es nicht so aber natürlich
irgendwie zu lesen dass man nicht
alleine damit ist sylvia plath oder auch
fast alle sind sehr prominente beispiele
kann kann trost sein und ich habe auch
wirklich das konzept nicht neu erfunden
als christ würde glaube ich seit
geschrieben wurde auch über alles dunkle
geschrieben aber eine depression darf
man nicht verwechseln mit einer
melancholie oder im weltschmerz über
diese männer verliehen den weltschmerz
diese andere formen von dunkelheit
sprechen wir später noch bleiben wir
noch kurz da der depression und bei
diesem bild weil das glaube ich wirklich
im bild ist was schon sehr gut trifft er
um es bei dieser depression geht also
die glasglocke ziel der platz schreibt
dass man sich eigentlich ein bisschen
fühlt wie ein totes baby unter dieser
glocke und dann guckt nach draußen und
denkt sich diese welt die ist furchtbar
mit der will ich eigentlich nichts mehr
zu tun haben dass das schlimmste ist
dass man selbst auch das schöne keinen
zugriff mehr hat
denn irgendwie sommer ist
und man selbst steht dort innerhalb von
dieser glasglocke und man hört alles
etwas dumpfer und man hört wie menschen
irgendwie draußen feiern und sich
verlieben und meine alte das potenzial
zu alldem aber man hat keinen zugriff
mehr es ist dieses bild ist ein
wahnsinnig gutes nach wie vor und ich
meine dass eine glasglocke gibt es keine
tür und im prinzip kann sie nur jemand
von außen
erheben da verein selbst ist es einfach
nicht so einfach es ist ein wirklich
starkes bild aber es ist auch ein
vernichtendes bild
ja aber ich kenne sind und sie haben
jetzt gesagt es gibt keine tür sieht der
platz beschreibt auch in dieser figur
dieser esther dass sie irgendwann merkt
dass es ihr besser geht die glasglocke
hebt sich aber sie weiß ganz genau sie
wird sich wieder senken sie schwer über
einer genau und sie kann nichts tun die
wird wieder erbarmungslos sich senken
leben sie selbst mit dieser angst gibt
es momente sie denken das war jetzt das
zweite mal dass ich in der klinik war es
jetzt ein drittes mal kommen jeden tag
es ist eine gewissheit die wir nicht
mich wirklich zum optimismus bemüht
mir die fähigkeit schenkt gute momente
wenn es mir gutgeht wahnsinnig
auszukosten ich habe ein großes talent
zum glücklichsein und ich habe viele
gründe zum glücklichsein und wenn die
sich zeigen kann ich irgendwie von
von irgendeinem schönen abend oder sowas
zu tränen gerührt sein das wäre
vielleicht das was übrig bleibt aber es
ist ein bedrohliches bild und es wird
wieder passieren es gibt sicherlich in
meiner familie eine genetische
prädisposition ich gehe nicht davon aus
dass ich in meinem leben jemals wirklich
ohne antidepressiva zu angekommen wären
ich habe immer wieder versucht sich
abzusetzen
und bin dann wieder in der klinik
gelandet
es ist extrem unheimlich
und das kann jedes ist kann wieder
passieren aber man muss auch begreifen
dass oder ich muss für mich begreifen
denn sonst wird es unerträglich dass
jedes gefühl geht es jetzt ein zustand
ist und zustände haben einen anfang ein
höhepunkt und dann klingen sie wieder ab
der literatur gibt es den satz this too
shall pass also auch dies wird vergehen
was sehr tragisch ist ein schönen
momenten und an weihnachten und was
tröstlich ist wenn man nicht mehr daran
glaubt und dadurch auch dass ich das
jetzt öfter schon erfahren habe weiß ich
dass es so ist und ich weiß auch
dass meine gefühle zu dem zeitpunkt zwar
ihre berechtigung haben aber deswegen
nicht recht haben und dass diese
gedanken nicht recht haben das weiß ich
weil ich das schon mal durchgemacht habe
und weil ich mir das auf schreibe jeden
tag und weil ich dann so ein bisschen
darauf zählen kann dass sie nicht
wahnsinnig interessant dass sie sagen
sie wissen dass diese gefühle und die
gedanken nicht recht haben sie haben
früher auch gesagt sie wissen dass es
durchaus gründe gibt fürs glück fürs
glücklichsein
ich kann mir aber vorstellen dass wenn
sie unter der glasglocke sind dass sie
nicht empfänglich sind für diese gründe
das wenn leute dann zu ihm sagen aber
guck doch mal du hast diese tolle bücher
geschrieben du bist wahnsinnig
erfolgreich das ist wunderschön du bist
jugend das leben liegt vor dir das wird
sie wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich
erreichen das ist mit das
allerschlimmste also jetzt das zweite
mal in der klinik war war mir durchaus
bewusst ich bin jetzt wirklich kein
superstar in berlin also was ich werde
da irgendwie erkannt werden
und dort war ich auch in einer gruppe wo
sofort jemand sich meldete und sagte sie
sei irgendwie sehr neidisch und in dem
moment wieso gott ich dafür gar nicht
sein ich habe keine berechtigung dazu
hier sind menschen deren beziehung
zerrüttet sind menschen die nicht wissen
in welcher wohnung sie zurückkehren nach
der klinik menschen die verwandte an
corona verloren haben und es ist
wahnsinnig schwer weil man kommt sich in
guten momenten furchtbar albern dabei
vor depressiv zu sein also warum aber
die depression schert sich nicht um so
was wie gründe oder umstände oder um
talent oder um geld oder irgendwas das
kann es deutlich einfacher machen dann
muss auch sagen zum beispiel armut ist
ein faktor der der depression sehr viel
leichter macht
aber umgekehrt gilt es halt eben nicht
und das ist ja auch ein großes anliegen
die wieder zu betonen was höre ich jetzt
so aus dass sie eigentlich in einer
privilegierten situation sind aber reich
sondern hat nicht davor gefeit trotzdem
an einer depression zu erkranken
jetzt wenn sich auch so herausstreichen
das ist nicht der künstler krankheit sie
sagen ja auch immer wieder sie sind
nicht wegen der depression kreativ
sondern trotz der repression und wenn
man sich dann fragt wie kriegen sie das
denn trotzdem hin dann sagen sie seien
einfach waren sie nicht effizient ja und
ich muss auch tatsächlich sagen nach
jedem buch denke ich immer noch dass es
eigentlich unmöglich ist ein roman zu
schreiben
während ich schreibe denke ich es mache
ich nie wieder das tue ich mir nie
wieder an und dann ähnlich wie eine
schwangerschaft amnesie und dann die
geburt verdrängen ist es dann raus ich
denke ich schreib gleich das nächste
es gab durchaus phasen wo es einfach
nicht gegen dieses buch hat auch echt
lange gebraucht und nicht weil ich
langsam tippe sondern weil ich gar nicht
tippe und nicht duschen kann
kolumnen gehen dann doch eher was
kurzstrecke ist aber langstrecke ist ist
anstrengend aber ich bin ein trotziger
mensch und ich habe eigentlich keine
lust mir von
von so einem blödsinn wieder
depressionen bisschen albern albernes
haustier ist ein schwarzer hund der die
hinterher trottet immer nicht braucht
und aber und ins tierheim geben kann
deswegen kostet halt im moment wo ich
kann waren sich aus binnen macht dann
alles ich stehe auf und frühstücke und
schreibe und treffe freunde und rufe
meine großmutter an und renne durch den
tag und
dann entstehen büchern jetzt haben sie
grad schon vorhin gesagt dass depression
in ihrer familie liegen es gibt da diese
unterscheidung zwischen endogenen und
exogenen depressionen also depressionen
die sozusagen von innen hier kommen die
rasta tun haben mit genetischen
veranlagungen zum beispiel und exogenen
ein trauma ein dramatisch daneben ist
zum beispiel bei seinem widerfährt sie
haben immer wieder sie hätten eigentlich
eine bilderbuch coverbilder buch
kindheit gehabt ich glaube aber dass wir
so aufregen trotz und zu sagen ihr müsst
jetzt nicht das gefühl haben meine
kindheit war schlecht aber wirklich gut
ist aber auch ein gutes verhältnis sehr
gutes verhältnis mit meiner familie aber
ich glaube die unterscheidung zwischen
energien exogenen ist gar nicht mehr so
hohe zeitgemäß denn am ende ist es ein
gemisch selbst wenn ich mir irgendwie
ein rede oder denke dass irgendwie alles
gut war kann durchaus und therapie sich
zeigen
schau doch mal genauer hin oder
beziehungsmuster wurde man immer dachte
so ist es halt also manchmal hilft
dieser blick durchaus von außen deswegen
würde ich auch nicht sagen
nur der medikamentöse weg ist eine
lösung oder nur der therapeutische weg
ist eine lösung sondern da muss man sehr
genau hinschauen und ich bin noch immer
sehr vorsichtig weil das so furchtbar
individuell ist
da irgendwie tipps zu geben weil ich
wirklich kein profi bin nicht mal mit
meiner eigenen depression ein profi bin
deswegen sollte man alles was ich hier
sage
wirklich nur als
mein erleben aufpassen nicht als tipps
bloß ist und die frage ist ja auch was
ist eigentlich überhaupt eine gute
kindheit was ist ein gutes leben und es
gibt einen text hier in dieser kolumbien
sammlung heute ist leider schlecht
beschwerden ums leben da gibt es einen
text in habe ich wahnsinnig gemacht der
heißt coni hat aids und da spielt
natürlich an auf diese r blonde heldin
eigentlich gleich haut ist wie sie und
wir müssen euch ganz kurz sagen als ich
ja so conny spielt fußball sie schreiben
sie wurden aus dem fußballverein
ausgeschlossen dass sich daneben
benommen haben conny macht pferdchen sie
wurden von einer qualle gebissen und
mussten ins krankenhaus
und dann kriegt man ja auch noch eine
katze während dessen sie urzeitkrebse
bekommen haben die kann man
wahrscheinlich auch nicht streicheln
sterben also nicht trüben wasser vor
sich conny conny habt sie jetzt nicht
aus der kindheit so waren sie nicht und
das ist tragisch weil es gibt wahnsinnig
tolle deutschsprachige kinder- und
jugendliteratur die kinder durchaus auch
ernst nimmt also peter härtling oder
auch ottfried preußlers krabat oder
sowas und ich fand das als kind schon
wahnsinnig also ich meine das ist ja
wirklich für dreijährige das ist schon
in ordnung ich habe noch andere toni
bekommt
jena oder ländlich schlecht oder ja ja
das würde schon unangenehm also dieses
nur bunte welt das fand ich als kind
schon nicht so richtig glaubwürdig ich
bin aber auch ganz froh dass ich nicht
nur hier mit aufgewachsen
mein conny konnte alles und
conny bekam alles coni hat die geilste
beste freundin und irgend überhaupt
keine probleme
es ist eigentlich ja das leben als
hochglanzprospekt und ihre kolumne dazu
heißt eben coni hat aids oder auch conny
läuft amok oder conny hat zoff mit den
eltern weil sie sagen 'hör mal auf sein
leben gibt es auch gar nicht wenn ich
dieses leben gäbe wer ist denn überhaupt
attraktiv
nein das ist natürlich im prinzip eine
ganz furchtbare vorstellung immer
glücklich zu sein also
utopia würde ich nicht als irgendwie
paradies begreifen und man brauche ich
auch dass schmerz und trauma und
verletzungen sind im besten fall ein
kontrastmittel mit dem man das leben
begreifen kann es gibt diesen
kalenderspruch die krise sei ein
produktiver zustand wenn man ihnen den
beigeschmack der katastrophe nimmt das
sind sprüche die funktionieren sehr gut
wenn die krise überwunden hat wenn man
gerade drin steckt hat sich dass hoeneß
an dann hilft das alles herzlich wenig
aber ich würde mich nie für irgendeine
zauber brille entscheiden mit der ich
irgendwie nur happy durch den tag gehe
denn ich finde durchaus das intensive
erleben
was wo ich bei wertvolles
und wenn es sich irgendwie gebärt mit
liebeskummer und weltschmerz und man
hört auf spotify die schlimmsten
herzschmerz songs und singt sie mit dann
kann es auch durchaus schön sein aber
der charakter depression ist einfach ein
anderer das ist einfach eine krankheit
und das ist kein kontrastmittel im
gegenteil das gehabt alles bio alles ist
beige alles ist nämlich alles ist dumpf
und
das einzige was wir vielleicht kurz
durchsetzt ist so was wie eine
panikattacke
das ist das gegenteil von
kontrastmitteln
noch einmal zurück zu ihrem text das
leben als hochglanzprospekt ich verstehe
absolut warum sie da ausschlag kriegen
und das nicht mögen
ich habe aber auch gedacht dass diese
conny bücher auch tun und warum sie
vielleicht so beliebt sind ist sie geben
sozusagen einen rhythmus vor eines
individuellen lebens in unserer
gesellschaft leider ist es ebenso man
kriegt meistens irgendwann taschengeld
mann entdeckt die bücher man fliegt
zuerst einmal man backt irgendwann pizza
mann zieht jeden wandeln und so weiter
es ist sozusagen das kinderleben die es
so vor sich hin lautet natürlich ist es
vielleicht zu schön gezeichnet was mich
immer geärgert hat ist ist natürlich
sehr stereotype familienbilder der
hammer packt den kuchen papa repariert
das auto aber insgesamt könnte es ja
auch halt bedeutet in einer welt gar
nicht dass es hochglanz mäßig sein muss
sondern dass es diesen rhythmus gibt und
dass es eigentlich für alle gleich ist
wie alle haben irgendwann ein wackelzahn
wir alle kriegen irgendwann den ersten
titel und so weiter ist ein schönes bild
mit dem wackelzahn ja manches gilt für
alle aber für ein mädchen was ist gerade
aus der ukraine flüchtet weiß ich nicht
ob das
ganz das gleiche ist und das leben kann
ein sehr sehr viel anders mitspielen
aber klar ein raster ist dass in dem wir
uns bewegen das da ist die schulzeit die
grundschulzeit vielleicht das gymnasium
vielleicht die ausbildung vielleicht das
studium
vielleicht die erste beziehung familie
und so weiter das ist ein grobes raster
was natürlich auch sicherheit gibt und
mir zum beispiel dann muss ich ehrlich
sein als sich
mit dieser depression vor mir selbst was
vorzuweisen hat was ich greifen kann wie
diese bücher dass ich weiß ich bin jetzt
irgendwie 30 geworden und ich habe drei
bücher vor 30 geschrieben und so was
natürlich ist es neurotisch aber das
sind pfeiler an den ich mich festhalten
kann wenn wir alles schlimm ist dass ich
weiß ich habe wenigstens was geleistet
das ist bestimmt nicht gut so aber es
ist de facto so und ich habe nicht
wenigstens was geleistet sondern wurden
ja wirklich über nacht ganz frisch und
zu einem literatur star hoch gefeiert es
gibt natürlich auch dunkle momente in
ihrer vita ich kann mir vorstellen dass
sie darüber überhaupt nicht mehr
sprechen wollen 2015 ich spreche
trotzdem kurz an ist in der welt am
sonntag diese kolumne schienen mit dem
titel warum ich der feminismus an oder
schreiben sie uns anderen dass der
meniskus eine charity-aktion für
unterprivilegierte frauen sei daraufhin
ging hat sich ein gigantischer sieht
shitstorm los sie wurden aber
gleichzeitig auch gesorgt sie brauchten
polizeischutz es war ein riesenrummel
denken sie im nachhinein nicht auch dass
dieses dieser ganze rummel auch war wie
er sich schlussendlich so sehr herunter
gezogen hat ich hatte damals die
überschrift mit dem antiken stadt
natürlich von mir und ich habe ein
höchst feministische mutter ist ging
nicht darum zu sagen dass sich gerade
der aktuelle netz vermitteln dass etwas
im kreis dreht anstatt irgendwie wieder
stark feminismus sich für sich selbst
einzusetzen und für frauen einzusetzen
alice schwarzer hat mir darauf
geschrieben ich mag sie sehr ganz gut
verstanden aber ich habe dann auch für
diesen artikeln preis mit irgendwie 8000
euro abgelehnt weil ihr gefällt springer
bei genau weil ich das nicht mehr wollte
ich habe das damals wirklich gar nicht
so richtig mitbekommen das war so viel
ich habe dann irgendwie laptop zu
gemacht und bin zu meinen eltern
gefahren und
stalker und so was das alles hat um die
seine dunkle seite viele dunklen seiten
man ist angreifbarer wenn man da steht
und im nachhinein habe ich aber auch mit
zärtlichkeit für mich damals war ich war
einfach wahnsinnig jung ich war 21
das studieren die meisten noch und ich
glaube es ist generell eine gute
lebensphilosophie sich nicht präventiv
alles zu verzeihen und zu sagen es egal
was du machst aber
im rückblick sich zu verzeihen ist für
mich etwas was wahnsinnig wichtig ist
die sachen die man eh nicht ändern kann
und deswegen schaue ich da fast ein
bisschen noch steige straft zurück und
würde die savanne von damen gern sagen
ok ok aber
klar dass da viel meine eltern waren
gerade backpacking irgendwo in
südamerika als das muss hält mit bislang
auf kein empfang hat nur nichts das
heißt nicht nur nach hause oder war gar
keiner ja die kamen dann irgendwann
wieder aber nicht weniger
der minister muss eine gesagt ist der
einbau auch auslöffeln
dann auch ganz gut hinbekommen
wechseln wir das thema oder drehen lesen
wissen weiter und kommen zu dieser eher
alltäglichen melancholie und traurigkeit
die frage wie wir überhaupt so was
menschen im leben stehen wo sie auch
denken da braucht es einiges an
standhaftigkeit ich habe schon erwähnt
sie machen dieses formats trick
philosophie das auf arte läuft und da
gibt es eine episode da sprechen sie
über diese stumpfe sinnlosigkeit die
einen manchmal befahren kann und da
sprechen wir schauen wir ganz kurz
gemeinsam rein
[Musik]
wieder einer dieser tage der himmel grau
der schädel brummt die lage düster
eigentlich spricht wenig für das leben
und noch viel weniger dafür aufzustehen
haben sich zuletzt verdreifacht und sie
könnten
ja ja schon klar die welt ist schlecht
klimawandel trump tod und verderben
alles geht den bach runter die
einfachste reaktion ist er immer decke
über den kopf ziehen weiter schlafen wer
aufgibt daraus schlafen des pessimismus
die einzig vernünftige haltung in einer
schlechten welt was macht das mit mir
wenn ich immer mit dem schlimmsten
rechnen schwarz
sehen sie den schwarz so ganz allgemein
gesprochen
ich finde
angemessen ist es im moment auf jeden
fall ich bin kein kulturpessimist denn
ich glaube das würde das leben recht
spaß los machen
aber man muss sich den glauben an die
menschheit gerade moment immer wieder
verdienen ich finde man sieht's moment
wohl das natürlich sehr tragisch ist an
der ukraine situation es ist wirklich
viel hilfsbereitschaft gibt das kann
irgendwie helfen
aber ich bin kein grund pessimist musste
ich auch gar nicht unbedingt sein dann
hätte ich noch noch was bei dem ich
irgendwie klarkommen muss
aber sie sagen in diesem ein spieler
auch eigentlich spricht wenig für das
leben
das ist natürlich etwas überzeichnet die
folge geht um pessimismus ich glaube es
ist einfach
wahrscheinlich mit den nachrichten die
wir immer auf der hand haben mit dem
smartphone mit der um die präsenz die
man bekommt mitbekommen von allem
schlechten
wahrscheinlich in der
menschheitsgeschichte selten einfacher
gewesen
zu verzweifeln und
samt zum beispiel fand ich dass ich
konnte es nicht fassen ist der gewählt
wurde
die rechten bewegungen die wird wieder
aufschwung hatten oder auch ja
putin jetzt
klar das kann ein verzweifeln lassen und
dann hilft es irgendwie nur den blick zu
wenden aber das ist ein aktiver vorgang
mehr halt viel anstrengung kostet immer
wieder sich vor augen zu halten dass
nicht alles so schlimm ist wie es auf
den push nachrichten auf dem handy
aussieht und dazu muss man sich
entscheiden werden während das unglück
sich relativ bereitwillig hinstellten
sagt hier bin ich und natürlich ist es
einfacher als ich daran fallen zu lassen
der mensch ist nicht zum glücklichsein
gebaut dann würden wir halt nur noch
wahrscheinlich recht glücklich unseren
höhen sitzen
fortschritt und so weiter kommt ja aus
einem mangel gefühl persönlicher
fortschritt aber auch der fortschritt
der menschheit und dieses gefühl scheint
recht intrinsisch uns bleiben in die dna
gegossen zu sein ich komme zu sprechen
auf die weltlage mit dem kriegen der
ukraine in dem klimawandel und so weiter
war auch in dem ein spieler gerade
sichtbar ich frage mich manchmal es gibt
ja noch diese sehr viel grundsätzlichere
sich im leben zurechtfinden müssen die
abgründe die sich auftun alleine
aufgrund der tatsache dass wir geworfen
sind in eine welt die uns erst einmal
fremd stumm und kalt gegenübersteht und
das ist ja so die existenzielle
sinnlosigkeit die uns beschäftigt und
ich glaube genau an die in diesem moment
kommen sie eigentlich mit ihrem trotzdem
oder dass sie sagen eigentlich ist trotz
meine lebensphilosophie ohne trotz
geht's nicht trotz des schönen trotz ist
trotz macht sich frei von allen
umständen
ja es gibt ihn überhaupt nur deswegen
wenn die umstände sagen nein sagte trotz
ja und wenn
die gesellschaftliche erwartung sagt das
geht nicht sagte trotz doch und im trotz
des eigentlich alles begründet der
fortschritt das wachstum
die freiheit und deswegen ist das ein
großes lebensthema ich habe aber auch
eine recht trotzige mutter hoffen sie
dass hier nicht
und das ist auf jeden fall lebensthema
von mir
und ich mag es und wie auch ich mag die
bockigkeit die dahinter steht
die sich nicht versperrt vor der
wirklichkeit
aber die sagt jetzt erst recht und ich
glaube das brauche ich jetzt fast
überlebenswichtig für mich
und
ich finde es auch eine so wenig
weibliche brave eigenschaft das mag ich
glaube ich auch dran ist das eigentlich
hat ja fast etwas kleinkind haftet
bockiges durchsetzungsvermögen
es ist eigentlich dieses brav gebügelte
sondern dieses
ich kann das extrem gut verstehen und
sie haben jetzt gerade gesagt trotz und
freiheit gehören ganz eng zusammen das
verstehe ich weil man sich aus
konventionen heraus boxt wie er sich aus
gleichzeitig gibt es sehr schöne
formulierung bei karl jaspers dem
existenz philosophen der mann gesagt hat
die unabhängigkeit ist still ohne trotz
das ist ein satz der mich immer
begleitet hat und zwar weil ich
einerseits natürlich verstehen kann dass
trotz sich zu seinen zusagen die fesseln
sprengen lässt aber gleichzeitig habe
ich immer gedacht hat trotz der bindet
einen auch so ein bisschen wieder ärger
wenn ich wahnsinnig trotz ich bin bin
ich doch immer noch in dieser abwehr
haut und eigentlich wäre doch die
unabhängigkeit die eigentliche freiheit
für viele bestimmt aber ich mag es mich
im leben und den umständen abzuarbeiten
ich kann auch wenig anfangen mit yoga
und meditieren und erleuchtung finden
und die welt um mich herum egal sein
lassen ich möchte das leben spüren ich
möchte auch den schmerz spüren und
deswegen muss ich darauf mit trotz
reagieren
und trotz kann ja auch was furchtbar
sanftes sein wenn jemand sagt ich möchte
für meine tochter ein besseres leben und
deswegen in ein anderes land flüchtet
oder sich dafür einsetzt dann hat es ja
auch durchaus was sanft das ist ja nicht
nur eine egoistische haltung sondern es
ist eine überzeugung die
größer ist als das was die welt einem
hinwirft und die kraft die darin steckt
finde ich schöner und ob ich mag auch
das dynamische daran und erst was ist
nur in dir niemand kann mir war aber ich
verstehe der punkt ist natürlich legitim
dann versuchen wir es mit albert kam ich
meinen camille der hat ja auch ist
eigentlich auch ein trotziger denker
kann man sagen weiß auch für ihn die
stille gibt wenn ihr an diesem mythos
von sisyphos denken mit dem stein hoch
rollen und immer wieder roter stein
zurück er probiert es wieder und wieder
er hat er zurück und waren natürlich
diese von dem mythos des sisyphos wo er
sagt wir müssen uns diesen sieg als
glücklichen menschen vorstellen
und viele leute meinen ja das hat damit
zu tun dass man irgendwie eben das glück
aus trotz sozusagen konzipiert ich bin
dennoch glücklich obwohl das leben
absolut ist vielleicht müssen wir uns
aber auch als glücklichen menschen
vorstellen weil die alternative
unerträglich ist vielleicht denkt man
gar nicht so sehr an sisyphos sondern
darüber nachzudenken dass jemand leidet
und dann weiter leidet und der stein
wieder runter rollt vielleicht werden
wir verrückt werden wir uns denken der
leidet bis in alle ewigkeit weil das ist
ein schutz des rezipienten mehr als des
protagonisten dieser geschichte das
finde ich interessant und dann bin ich
auch noch interessant dass ich ja schon
glaube ich so eine deutung gibt vom
comedian nicht ganz gerecht wird nämlich
diese vorstellung dass leben ist absurd
aber die absolut kommt dabei komme
dadurch zustande dass wir als menschen
vom leben etwas erwarten was das leben
nicht hergibt also noch einmal diese
stille dieses stille stimme geben über
dieses gefühl ich bin in eine welt
gestellt die nicht antwortet und dieses
gefühl ist eigentlich das absurd das ist
eigentlich ein die absurdität kommt aus
einfachen verhältnis daher zwischen den
menschen und der welt vom ensi natürlich
jetzt zeichen dass eine person die von
der welt alles will und noch mehr will
und es ausreizen will man nimmt
natürlich diese absurdität vielleicht
doch diese sinnlosigkeit fast zu weil da
so wenig kommt gleichzeitig nimmt aber
der aktions spielraum zu und ich merke
dass ich etwas bewirken wenn man das
wirklich jetzt sehr plastisch macht und
von der hohen philosophie sich etwas
entfernt in dem moment wo ich darüber
offen schreiben dass ich in einer klinik
war es unter depressionen leidet mache
ich damit möglichkeit raumfahrer anderer
auf das klingt jetzt sehr nach ihren
motiven aber das ist einfach de facto so
wenn ich dann auf instagram nachrichten
kriege von jugendlichen die zum ersten
mal mit ihrer schulpsychologen darüber
sprechen dass es vielleicht nicht normal
ist oder
leute mich um rat bitten oder so was
gehen diese
diese auswirkungen über mein eigenes
wohlbefinden dass ich bin nicht
besonders gut mit self care und auf mich
achten
aber ich mag diesen wirkungsraum den man
für andere aufmacht und es ist irgendwie
schön bestseller zu schreiben aber
tatsächlich ist auch wenn es natürlich
sehr hohe klint wenn man irgendwie
veränderung mit anstößt wenigstens und
das kann man ja ganz vielen berufen also
das ist ja nicht auf die künstler
beschränkt und ich glaube deswegen
möchte ich mich abarbeiten weil die
wirkung die es davon gibt ist nicht nur
meine sondern ich habe mit 16 gearbeitet
in der arche das ist eine auffangstation
für kids aus schwierigen verhältnissen
war ein kind die
migrantischen hintergrund und sollte
eigentlich aufs gymnasium und sowas und
von berne nachricht bekommen dass jetzt
im medizin studiert
das sind kleine und das ist abarbeiten
an der wirklichkeit ich tue mich einfach
mit dem philosophen sehr schwer die
irgendwie da sitzen und darüber
nachdenken ja so ist es halt und dieses
rein theoretische deswegen mag ich es
krieg philosophiert auf die straße gehen
und vielleicht bin ich auch gar nicht so
intellektuell aber das ist ja
interessant weil genau diese figur
mensch in der revolte dass das dann
später kam war eigentlich auch sagt
dieses gemeinsam solidarisch unterwegs
seien füreinander einstehen das ist auch
das was uns aus dieser sinnlosigkeit
heraus
eine andere möglichkeit mit dieser
sinnlosigkeit und zu gehen ist da die
ironie und die beherrschen sie ja auch
ganz hervorragend nicht nur bei conny
aids hat in diesem buch ein ende in
sicht gibt es eine szene ist eigentlich
meine lieblingsszene da gehen die beiden
frauen steigen auch in so einem hotel
und man geht die sprinkleranlage los
also man denken es gibt jetzt ein
braunes vorfall und geht die
sprinkleranlage los und heller diese
eltern der schlagersängerin betrieb das
badezimmer im juli sitzt gerade in der
badewanne und möchte sich eigentlich mit
einer nagelschere die pulsadern öffnen
aber sie ist eigentlich wird ertappt bei
einem suizidversuch um diese
sprinkleranlage läuft ich mein mehr kann
man die dramatik der situation ja nicht
brechen
ironie etwas was ihnen auch selbst im
leben vertraut ist also ich finde es
große zeitverschwendung lustig zu
schreiben über dinge die schon lustig
sind für mich ist humor eine art von
regenschirmen die man über diesen sturm
von wirklichkeit der jeden tag da ist
halten kann und es ist für mich eine
erhebung und frei machen und
emanzipation von umständen weil ich das
narrativ auf einmal beherrschen dadurch
dass ich einen humoristischen zugriff
habe und die sprache habe kann ich eine
situation einfach anders deuten und
viele makler schwarze oder makaber sein
für mich ist es ein
mechanismus mit dem ich gut arbeiten
kann und ich finde gerade das das
komische im tragischen zu suchen ist die
schönste aufgabe die ich persönlich als
autoren haben kann und was mir am
meisten spaß macht denn
was schon lustig ist muss nicht lustig
beschrieben werden aber humor ist ein
werkzeug der
hadernden und der zweifelnden und
derjenigen die sich umschauen in dieser
welt und alles absurd finden
und die großen humoristen sind durchaus
auch leute die ist nicht nur leichter
mit ich denke zwar scheint max goldt den
ich ganz toll finde das sind jetzt alles
nicht leute mit clownsnase durch berlin
laufen und für mich ist es eine
emanzipation und sprache zu haben das
narrativ zu beherrschen nicht einfach
nur reinzufallen wahrscheinlich merke
ich jetzt gerade im gespräch ist diese
emanzipation von umständen ein leben das
thema humor ist eines der werkzeuge dich
dafür nutze ich es ja vielleicht auch
irgendwie nicht form schon trotz ein
stück wie viele menschen kommen damit
überhaupt nicht gut zurecht auch in
meinen texten
ich bin nicht so sensibel damit was die
lesarten von anderen angeht ich hatte
beim
beim ersten buch hatte ich das meinem
damaligen freund gegeben gesagt kann so
stand darin irgendwas menschenverachtend
ist aus versehen weil ich mit so einem
relativ derben sarkastischen umgangston
aufgewachsen bin und den auch immer noch
schätze und da muss man heute ja auch
aufpassen man hat ja wirklich quasi
immer sekunden hat man schied dorn am
haus ich weiß nicht wie sehr sie sich
aus stimme einer generation empfinden
ich finde das ja sowieso immer schwierig
mit diesen generationen sind aber
trotzdem schwer oder was umgekehrt sagen
ich finde es interessant dass ich zb an
diesem tisch auch mit sophie passmann
gesprochen habe ich schätze die bücher
sehr und die kolumnen von nina kunz
einer schweizerin sind alle ungefähr
gleich alt und in diesen texten geht es
ja schon immer auch zum beispiel um die
frage wie stehe ich eigentlich in der
öffentlichkeit sind alles sehr präsent
in den sozialen medien man muss
aufpassen dass man keinen schutz darum
kriegt gleichzeitig ist eigentlich alles
was man tut so ein sieg gelingen also
was man trägt was man isst wie man sich
frisiert alles wird gedeutet alles ist
ausdruck eines bildes das man stimmt
abgibt mich beeindruckt das zum glück
nicht so sehr
weil ich vielleicht auch einfach mit mir
selbst beschäftigt bin um mich dann noch
mit anderen zu beschäftigen und ich bin
durch die harte schule gegangen ich
hatte einen schutzraum der in der
dimension weil die einfach völlig
abgedreht gebaut und auch den text nicht
angemessen
und danach habe ich für mich beschlossen
dass ich hasse nur noch ernst nehmen von
leuten mit denen ich auf meinen
geburtstag feiern würde
das war jetzt erstmal ein kognitiver
beschlossene intellektueller beschluss
natürlich holt mich sachen immer noch
wieder ein aber ja ich gesagt
beeindruckt mich das zum glück relativ
wenig vielleicht habe ich da irgendwie
glück dass ich ein relativ stabiles
selbst habe
und auch weiß man kann sowieso nicht
allen recht machen und manche mögen dich
weil sie dich schön finden und manche
mögen dich nicht weil sie dich schön
finden und am ende ist das furchtbar
egal und weder schönheit noch jugend
noch sonst irgendwas ist da immer aber
dieses
sprachrohr einer generation ist
natürlich totaler blödsinn ich wollte es
nicht von dem plenum 30-jähriger gewählt
und das ist würde ich auch gar nicht für
mich in anspruch nehmen ich bin froh
wenn ich für mich selbst sprechen darf
und wenn das auch noch geöffnet umso
leiser da treffen sie sich
wahrscheinlich sogar mit sophie passen
und er sagt es gibt diese generation gar
nicht denn es gibt sehr viel mehr
klassen zum beispiel und die 30-jährigen
hipster in berlin sind ganz andere wie
30 jährigen
irgendwo in einem ich habe auch mal mega
und die hat hier aufwachsen ich haben
text darüber geschrieben das ist es auch
die grenze verläuft nicht zwischen 30
und 40 sondern zum beispiel zwischen ost
und west oder zwischen
bayern und links also jemand mit dem ich
irgendwie einem bayerischen dorf
aufgewachsen bin und sehr
traditionsbewusst sehr katholisch mit
dem habe ich die auf der gleichheit ist
deutlich weniger gemein als mit dem 50
jährigen schriftsteller in berlin
derweil sie nicht zu den gleichen
lesungen oder so es geht das hat sich
verschoben ist eine klasse frage ist
eine frage wo man wohnt wie man wohnt es
ist eine geldfrage
und ich glaube gerade durchs internet
und die neu vernetzung die wir haben
können ist es auch eine frage vor allem
vom umfeld in dem man sich bewegt und
das können auch viel die digitalen räume
seien und in diesen digitalen räumen
dass sie aber trotzdem so dass ein
stückweit abhängig ist von likes oder
zumindest schon irgendwie auch nach
diesen likes schiebt sie gehen ja sehr
offensiv mit diesem öffentlichen raum um
es gibt ein video auf ihrem instagram
kanal wo sie beschreiben wie sie sich
gefühlt haben als sie ende in sicht
gerade
abgegeben haben oder oder beendet haben
sie weinen auf diesem wir sehen hier das
bild sie warnen in diesem kurzen videos
und da habe ich mich dann gefragt warum
genau posten sie das ist das auch eine
form von sagen guck mal es gibt auch
schlechte momente verwechseln guter
moment ich bin total überfordert aber
auf lange hund aber ich bin eigentlich
gerade durch mit dem buch es ist
eigentlich eher ein gott dieses
irgendwas feld von mir ab diese strecke
die fünf jahre lang war ist jetzt
vorläufig zu ende gegangen abschnitt von
einem lebensabschnitt auch große
überforderung wenn hat die kamera
draufgehalten
eigentlich eher für ja genau ich eher
für mich aber ich wollte das dann teilen
war das ist großer moment andere
heiraten und teilen das buch ein buch
geboren ja ich habe ein buch geboren
und ich meine natürlich ist es blödsinn
man ist eine sozialen medien nicht
authentisch allein durch die auswahl was
man postet was nicht durch das
kuratieren
ist es nicht authentisch und viele mögen
sagen das wirkt authentisch und so
weiter und ja ich habe mich doch nicht
verstellt aber allein die auswahl was
ich posten was nicht mache keinen
unterschied was ich drunter schreiben
macht einen unterschied
ich bin gar nicht so begabt ein social
media wie viele andere ich bin auch
wenig auf social media ich poste zwei
sachen aber ich konsumiere sie nicht
zumindest nicht auf diesen üblichen
plattformen
weil mir das nicht besonders gut tun
würde deswegen bin ich irgendwie auch
mal sehr sehr dankbar dass ich weil ich
brauch tatsächlich wie jeder vernünftige
mensch bestätigung von außen aber dass
sich die auf unterschiedlicher ebene
habe mit lasern zum beispiel dieses buch
lesen mit leuten die dann vielleicht
street für das wir schauen mit wie gut
bin ich als freundin wie gut bin ich als
tochter wie gut
dar ausfindig setzt sich das zusammen
und da ist bestimmt ein stück vom kuchen
vielleicht auch so was vielleicht aber
jetzt nicht so furchtbar bedeutend
business aber ich weiß nicht ob ich
jetzt wirklich wenn er steht 5000 oder
6000 ob das ein unterschied in einem
glücksempfinden machen würde bezweifelt
er sieht natürlich auch da schon
privilegiert 5000 leibfarth jetzt nicht
jeder und viele schienen vielleicht auf
20 oder 30 leid ich hatte aber auch mal
eine zeit da hatte ich auch nur 20
eltern als ich dabei ich hab's nicht
primär unglücklich als jetzt ich glaube
was mich interessiert ist vielleicht
mehr noch ich meine wir sind sehr
unterschiedlich alt sie können jetzt
nicht gerade meine tochter sein aber es
ist trotzdem so dass es eine große
altersdifferenz gibt zwischen uns und
ich denke oft wie ist es wohl jung zu
sein und ein stück weit auch immer in
der öffentlichkeit zu stehen gerade wenn
man etwas erreicht hat und meine sorge
wäre glaube ich so ein bisschen dass wir
sehr schnell dazu gedrängt werden immer
um uns zu kreisen und eben zu kuratieren
unser leben zu kuratieren immer zu
überlegen mit dem außen blick die
wirklich gerade wie sehe ich gerade aus
ist das instagram abo kann ich das
irgendwo posten und dadurch gehen doch
die wahren geschichte verloren oder bin
ich jetzt total okay war mäßig und
absolut
nun erstens mangelt es mir an
vergleichsmöglichkeiten wenn ich neben
dieser gegenwart deswegen kann ich das
nicht anders erleben so
wie sie jetzt auch nicht
das so erlebt haben aber ich glaube nein
auch wenn meine stieftochter und so
weiter das sind komplett authentische
gefühle und ob die jetzt sich bild
verkleidet und davon video macht er
nicht glaube ich nicht das ist ein
großer unterschied macht ich glaube was
man was eine große rolle spielt ist der
vergleich und ist das konsumieren davon
und in welcher form man konsumiert und
so weiter aber ich weiß nicht wer der
unterschied zu früher angeht zur klassen
schönsten mit der man sich verglichen
hat
ich fand es schwierig in bayern das ist
die einzige war die nicht getauft da und
ich bayerische konnte also sucht man
sich sein unglück in den teenager jahren
gehört es auch dazu sich das so oder so
zu suchen und gleichzeitig muss ich
sagen gerade die generation noch eins
unter mir durch die sozialen medien
reden offen wie nie über dinge wie
mentale gesundheit reden offen über
sexuelle identitäten
haben ein selbstverständnis von dingen
mit denen selbst meine generation noch
hadert sprechen genauso darüber dass sie
glauben dass sie depressiv sind wir
irgendwie was anderes und haben dann
wieder heil deswegen schneidig wie immer
das kann ich wahnsinnig gut
nachvollziehen und ich glaube das hat ja
wirklich etwas das man irgendwie viele
dinge so endlich motivieren kann
gleichzeitig bleibt dann kreisen um sich
selbst und was ich unglaublich schön von
ihrem buch ist es die eigentlichen cebu
heller gut das ist jetzt natürlich die
ältere figur aber wo sie sozusagen
wieder ins leben zurückfindet ich wo sie
realisiert ich habe eine schutzbefohlene
wenn ich eigentlich ist das 1 1 ein
altbau kann der begriff aber sie hat
eine schutzbefohlene und sozusagen nicht
mehr alleine ums licht zu kreisen
sondern um andere zu greifen nichts
macht verlässlich glücklicher als zu
helfen als in der klinik war
begannen gerade der ukraine krieg und
das war ganz komisch weil da nicht
richtig du geredet wurde und wir
konzentrieren uns selbst ich als sehr
sehr schwierig wird dann auch etwas
früher gang und habe jetzt wirklich gar
nicht wenn sie viel aber im hauptbahnhof
da irgendwie mitgeholfen klamotten
verhalten nichts nichts wichtiges oder
sowas aber da und wie zu sehen es geht
nicht um mich und ich kann bewirken und
so was
es macht gar nichts wenn man aus
egoistischen gründen gut ist es ist
total in ordnung wenn man ein ehrenamt
annimmt weil man sich selbst besser
fühlt man braucht nicht selbstlos motive
um selbstlos zu handeln und ist auch
okay wenn man davon für sich profitiert
denn natürlich stimmt das haben sie sich
selbst kreisen
macht nun gott glücklich alle anderen
nicht wirklich nicht wirklich sie haben
ihn in diesem buch hier auch ist ein
text abgedruckt da haben sie tipps
gegeben so werden sie ihre traurigkeit
unglaublich lustige kolumne finde ich
das schreiben sie leben sie sich etwas
pflege intensives zu einem hund ein
sky-abo eine schuppenflechte dann haben
sie keine zeit mehr sich um ihre
traurigkeit zu kümmern und die geht ein
wenn man sich nicht um sie kümmert
klugscheißer ronja ich finde das ehrlich
gesagt wirklich klug und ich denke
manchmal nicht wenn sie meine handfeste
depression geht ich finde dich da könnte
ich mir jegliche tipps aber so ganz
grundsätzlich diese schlechte stimmung
die man mal hat dieses drama denn dass
man es ums eigene leben macht hier und
einfach zu sagen kümmere dich um etwas
gibt ihr mühe mit etwas lass dich drauf
ein aber hör auf dich selbst für den
nabel der welt zu halten
ist auch durch ein problem das zum
beispiel leute die irgendwie schon der
depressive episode das was hat man dass
man das schnell zur identität nimmt das
ist brandgefährlich denn man ist so viel
mehr als das und gerade bei traurigkeit
und ich meine viele werden das gefühl
zumindest jetzt kennen wo sie vielleicht
in corona jahr zum ersten auf sich
selbst zurückgeworfen waren das ist
nicht nur angenehm und macht nicht nur
glücklich und dann auch nichts tun so
können nicht raus gehen zu können eben
auch nicht aber prinzipiell mit jammern
kann man schon kolumnen füllen aber
glücklich macht dann doch leider
langfristig nicht
wenn wir über dieses glück sprechen was
es bedeutet sich um andere zu kümmern
lassen sie mich noch über die tiefe
traurigkeit sprechen die dann dazu führt
dass man tatsächlich vielleicht nicht
mehr leben will das thema dieses buches
eigentlich wird in dem buch ja klar dass
die beiden ebenen suizid begehen möchten
sie sagen an einer stelle dann aber doch
auch eigentlich verbietet man sich dass
das ist nicht in ordnung da ich das ja
es gibt eben so einen satz zu sagen sie
man schule des die nahestehenden sich
das leben nicht zu nehmen
ja ich meine das ist eine prinzipielle
frage ob das leben ein geschenk ist oder
nicht die auch viel zu großes für hier
aber mal man weiß macht durch studien
dass der grund für viele
suizidgefährdete warum es nicht tun das
umfeld ist was man halt mit in die
traurigkeit reist und ins verderben
mitreißt und sowas und ich meine die
hoffnungen gewarnt die vielleicht müssen
mit geben kann ist der tod ist etwas
absolutes
und das leben ist etwas dynamisches ist
etwas was sich ändern kann und ändern
wird
der tod nicht das finde ich ist ein
argument was fürs leben spricht dass man
nicht wissen kann ab morgen etwas
erfinden erfunden wird mit demenz
depression weggeht ich glaube in belgien
man fall von einer jungen frau die es
geschafft hat aufgrund ihrer schweren
depressionen sterbehilfe in anspruch zu
nehmen und sehr lange gebraucht musst du
zeigen dass sie austherapiert ist es
hilft natürlich diesen große fragen auf
aber zu sehen wie erleichtert diese
junge frau war nicht mehr diesen
leidensdruck zu haben
er weiß aber wer bin ich dass ich leuten
hoffnung schenken oder nehmen darf ich
werde genauso wie sie nicht urteilen
wollen und gleichzeitig finde ich diesen
satz klug was man den nahestehenden
vielleicht schuldet vielleicht ist
schuld ein zu großes wort aber das ist
ja eigentlich mit diesen
schutzbefohlenen oder diese
vorstellungen ihr leben leben nicht nur
für uns allein ihr leben im gefüge und
vielleicht spontanen also wenn man nur
für sich selbst lebt nur für die eigene
entfaltung und
weil sie nicht für den eigenen fan oder
sowas dann macht man sein leben sehr
sehr klein
nun macht sich sehr sehr unglücklich
damit und es kann auch sehr schnell
zerbrechen ich glaube deswegen ist es
allein schon kein guter umgang sich
selbst als teil eines systems zu
begreifen als teil einer gemeinschaft
ist etwas was
ich fasse überlebensnotwendig ist und
dieses nur um sich selbst kreisen und
selbstverwirklichung und so weiter
sieht das gut genug aus habe ich das
schön gemacht wie erfolgreich ist mein
mann sind meine kinder schon chinesisch
unterricht
das ist so unnötiger stress und wir
haben schon so viel stress den uns gar
nicht selber machen müssen von außen
deswegen ja
sie haben ja in dieser corinna zeit
geheiratet war der muss sozusagen oder
der grund dafür dass sie eine
schutzbefohlene sein wollen oder dass
sie in schutzbefohlenen brauchte ich
glaube das war er trotzdem nur irgendwie
alles düster ist irgendwie ein zeichen
zu setzen
wenn ich zurückschaue auf diese jahre
das nicht nur eingesperrt sein da war
sondern irgendwie auch an die feiern ein
großes fest mit großes fest weil es
zwischen diesen zwei lockdown zwar und
der durfte man gerade 50 leute haben
mittelgroßes fest sehr schönes fest mit
familie und so
ja das war ein bisschen trotz und ich
bin eigentlich die ideen familiäres
system eingebunden zu sein finde ich
sehr schön für mich das kann aber
durchaus auch sein dass das mit
langjährigen freunden ist wo ich mich
dann mit der tochter kümmern oder das
kann alles mögliche sein ist es auch
eine form von trotz gegenüber was haben
denn überhandnehmen von sehr losen
liebes formen die im moment so buhnen
dass man eigentlich nicht wenn man
polyamorie oder möglichst freefloat im
single- und da martina und damals stand
also ich weiß definitiv nicht ob ich mit
für immer mit beiden zusammen sein werde
was ich in dem moment wusste ist dass
ich will so ich kann auch nicht in die
zukunft schauen und wenn es zerbrechen
sollte dann zerbricht ist aber dann war
ich zumindest in einem moment meinem
leben
einen jahren meinem leben sehr sicher
dass das etwas ist was ich will ich bin
noch nicht jemand der auf ex beziehung
bitter zurückschaut nie sondern ich
ziehe immer der mehrwert da raus und
denken für diese phase im leben war es
vielleicht das angemessen ich hatte aber
vielleicht bisschen glück und mein
männer mit glück an alle ich glaube von
ordnung aber ich finde es mal selbst
tragisch wenn eine ehe kaputt geht und
dann disqualifiziert man damit all die
guten augenblicke die man vielleicht
auch hatte aber trotzdem ja vorbei sein
dann ist es so wie vielleicht ich die
entscheidung für etwas ja auch eine form
von trotz weil man ja sozusagen sagt und
ich mache es trotzdem auch wenn die
evidenz vielleicht dagegen spricht ja
absolut zu sagen alles zerbricht und
soja wir vielleicht nicht
außerdem setzt dieses für immer freiheit
haben wollen macht nur unglücklich beim
schreiben es ist so wenn man nur
freiheit hat dann weiß man nicht was man
schreibt im prinzip würde ich am
liebsten ein reizwort geschichte
schreiben wie früher in der schule drei
worte kamera
moderatorin glas traurigkeit schreibt
eine geschichte mit diesen vier wörtern
ich bin gespannt
also ein spieler noch und ähnlich ist es
auch im leben macht sich komplett was
vor wenn man denkt dass in der großen
freiheit das glück steckt denn da steckt
auch das unverbindliche drin versteckt
das ablehnen jede langfristigkeit drin
da steckt drin dass man eigentlich immer
nur vom moment abhängig ist dass der an
glücklich machen kann und nichts
längerfristiges und sich gegen alles zu
entscheiden um die freiheit zu haben es
dir ja nicht aufgeht und in einer
entscheidung die alle anderen weg macht
liegt eine freiheit die gebärt sich nur
sehr anders und das ist eine frage die
ich mag das ist ja eigentlich auch schon
wieder existenzialistisch spiele so viel
auch wenn sie gesagt haben sie haben es
nicht so mit diesem film wird schon okay
ja das kommt eigentlich auch bei
kirkegaard die wahre freiheit ist die
entscheidung ja erschwerung genau an
sich hat oder auch dabei ja das denke
ich auf jeden fall jede getroffene
entscheidung sorgt dafür dass man
indikativ lebt und nicht mehr im
konjunktiv das leben im was wäre wenn
ist so anstrengend und es ist schon
anstrengend genug mit einer entscheidung
lässt es sich leben mit einer nicht
getroffenen entscheidungen nicht und man
kann auch entscheidungen durchaus
bereuen die entscheidung muss nicht
perfekt sein man kann später
zurückschauen und sagen warum habe ich
den geheiratet wie konnte ich mich in
dem irren
dann hat man aber trotzdem zu einem
zeitpunkt gewusst ich wollte dass ich
konnte dass das ist freiheit
entscheidung treffen zu können und wir
haben diese großartige freiheit in
diesen unordentlichen jahrtausend
bekommen und wir sollten sie nutzen und
wir sollten nicht
obdachlos nur herum flotten und das
beste hoffen und das ist für sie wichtig
dass sie entscheiden oder ist das auch
okay wenn andere für sie und dass man
glaubte habe ich dir schon wieder der
traum ja das ist tatsächlich so und
autorität habe ich nicht so ich bin noch
ganz froh dass ich in meinen jobs
relativ viel selbst bestimmen kann
obwohl natürlich etwas struktur sicher
gut tun würde aber
ich muss schon selber entscheiden sonst
ist keine entscheidung das ist zu lassen
sie nicht zum schluss noch einen tipp
von ihnen trotzdem beherzigen weil sie
haben nämlich mal 100 tipps für alle
gegeben die weder blockflöte noch
triangel spielen und trotzdem eine bühne
wollen da gibt es einige die schauen zu
und überlegen sich was sollte da tun ich
noch der typ 64
zitat einer schriftstellerin joyce carol
oates die schreibt sei froh und
hoffnungsvoll aber erwartet das
schlimmste das ich eine ganz schöne
spannung mögen sie die zum schluss nach
auflösen ich meine das ganz schön man
lebt im wie schön könnte es sein man
kann dort beschäftigt seines auszumalen
und man kann ein bisschen vorbereitet
sein dass das alles nicht klappt und wir
leben in einem entspannungszustand so
ist der mensch so bleibt der mensch und
wenn man es wenigstens erkennt macht das
vielleicht ein bisschen erträglicher und
dann kann man ein bisschen bockig
zumindest hoffen dass es doch noch
irgendwie gut kommt war
von rennen vielen herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch
vielen dank ihnen das hier sein durfte
ja wer weiter lesen mag wir verlosen
diese signierten welcher teil nehmen an
der verlosung können sie auf meine
instagram account oder auf unserer
sendung seite unter der rubrik mehr zur
sendung
nächste woche trifft ist oslo scheck mit
sicherheit einer der lebendigsten denker
unserer zeit und immer ein ereignis und
jetzt gleich zu einem der mit seiner
kunst das publikum verzaubert den
bildhauer maler und grafiker not vital
der soeben den renommierten bündner
kulturpreis gewonnen habt viel vergnügen
mit dem film eine gute zeit des paares
[Musik]